how can I help you help with that letter
I sent you is some sort of order or
something what tax bracket are you
finding yourself in oh that's why I
hired you as my CPA
how much do you a great question not
nearly enough compared to my male
co-workers can you believe that
not nearly enough it's not right make
like ten times as much as I do
so from your email I saw that you
haven't paid taxes since 2015 very hard
for me it's a lot of work which makes it
very expensive but let's start off with
what's your profession a service service
end customers every single day a month
how many clients do you have five ten a
day last year was more hello hey how can
I help you no you are not you're staring
at my breasts are you staring at my
brain you chose that outfit you gotta be
kidding me
yeah why it out there for the world to
see Bobe tax free not okay okay calm
down
not pay you later I cannot believe you
I'm gonna call my uncle Paulie and have
them come here and snap yeah I'll pay
you in cash man
hello my computer's not working fix it
my computer is not working I want to
talk to my manager are you not well
educated enough to get a better job huh
- what is it did you send me the address
that's broken